it is it is an incredible honor to be
here tonight to to celebrate Richard
Donner for any number of reasons and to
stand here with Jeff after so many years
together we have some stories a lot of
stories oh there any number of reasons
that it's an honor not the least of
which the dick and his wife Lauren gave
me my first unpaid job in Hollywood
my first part-time job in Hollywood my
first full-time job in Hollywood and my
first producing credit of which it's the
only reason I'm standing here the other
reason is because the film's dick made
inspired me to even want to go down that
track and of course in particular
Superman the movie is still to this day
the archetypes of the perfect superhero
film origin story and we watch it before
we make almost any one of our films and
that's been the case for the past 17
years since I left the fold
to go work for for Marvel there was a
word dick has a very good vocabulary and
there was a word that I was never able
to pronounce but I always understood
which was verisimilitude and he used
that word while making Superman one and
I first learned that not because it's
hanging above Dick's office which it was
for many years but because I saw him
talking about it in the ABC making of
Superman special when I was a kid and it
it basically means be truthful honor the
source material believe in it take it
seriously and that is what we strive to
do and jon favreau on the very first
Marvel Studios production copy that and
put it above his doorway and the and the
other thing that dick did and I'm so
honored to be here and standing here
Kevin it's it's just so wild and and and
great but the other thing that really
inspired me about Superman is when I
worked for dick I would I do everything
I would research hot tubs planes you
know also gas this car up which I'll
talk about later and and and I'd also go
into this you had this giant bathroom at
Warner Bros
and it was basically a storage room he
just threw all sorts of trash in there
and I was like this guy creepy guy going
through his trash and I found this
Superman script that was it was like 300
pages and I I pulled it out I go dick
what is this and he said oh that's the
first script from Superman that they
sent me I couldn't believe it I read
through a Kevin I looked at and they had
a scene it where Superman's looking for
Lex Luthor and he flew down and is a
bald guy and he turns around it's Telly
Savalas and he's like who loves you baby
and and I was like it's crazy and Dick
said you know and he's told the story a
lot how the salkinds called him and said
we're going to give you a million
dollars to direct this movie but it was
really as much as the collects money I
think is really more about he said I
think give me a million dollars but then
I got the script and it was so terrible
he said I have to save Superman and and
he did and that's why he took it because
he loved the character so much this
American icon and he had so much passion
for it he said I can't let this happen
and and he made the greatest superhero
film still ever